i don't know if it was the fine
or if it was uh damien lillard popping
in the comments on his ig live
or maybe he took a refresher course in
chess and realized that if you ain't a
king a queen
a bishop a knight or a rook
that makes you a pawn the pawns are
useful that's why they own the board
i don't know what it was but uh kyrie
irving
uh broke his brief media boycott
uh earlier today check it out
come on man y'all got to do better than
that you got to tell me when we ain't
got it
like
20 second timeout 20 second timeout i
said the only thing i want off the top
of the show
is the kyrie irving sound this is that's
all i said i watched this was the
carrier exhaust
it's serious this is a serious inside
baseball that's what i said i want i
said i want the kyrie irving sound off
the top of the show
we come in earlier we come in early in
the show not there
see that's what kyrie talking about you
got to be there bam i need you i need
you i need you post up i need you on the
elbow i need you
kevin running point guys i'm running
point guard here i need you in your spot
i need the ball where i want it i need
you in your spot we'll play the sound in
a second apparently
okay hurry up we'll play it in a second
michael he broke his silence
all right he broke his silence uh your
initial thoughts
i don't know if you've heard it i've
read it he said the pawn thing was
misunderstood
uh or misconstrued that he wasn't
calling anybody pawns
um what would you think of the fact that
kyrie actually spoke to media which we
should hear momentarily
okay this is what i think about kyrie
you remember at the beginning of the
season mike you said
beginning of the football season you
said cam newton
is the most fascinating person in the
nfl for you this is way back in
september right
this is before they even played a game
you just thought the idea of
cam newton going to the patriots and
playing for bill belichick and how this
was going to
play out was fascinating to you kyrie
irving
is that guy for me uh in in 2020 21
and i'll tell you more after we hear
this now because we got this out right
now boom
we do eureka
oh we saw i thought we had athena oh
come on you know i thought
you know i misunderstood it but anyway
uh he is that guy he's that guy for me
this is this is this is a case of the
mondays are the is this the mondays
we're having here right now is that what
we're doing no
no we're doing this okay but i'm gonna
tell you i'm gonna tell you why he's
he's out for me because he is clearly
trying to
and and i don't think it's clear yet
what what he's trying to do
but he's got a vision for his own career
mike and
he's got a vision for his own storyline
his own narrative
and nobody outside of i think kevin
durant
truly understands what it is and he is
trying to make sure that happens like
everybody some people are still confused
why he left cleveland okay he's past
that why he left cleveland with lebron
he didn't want to play with lebron
anymore came to boston
he was excited about going to boston
then he didn't want to be there anymore
either
so i just want to know what's going on
i want to go i want to know what's going
on with kyrie irving because he sees
something
he sees something that is is
greater than anything that he's
experienced in his career i think that's
the basketball side
and i'm also curious to see if he keeps
he keeps capitalizing
art i'm not gonna be a grammar geek and
say
stop capitalizing that but he keeps
capitalizing art when he seems when he
sends out these statements of hey enjoy
the art
this is about the love and peace enjoy
the art of basketball
there's something basketball wise that
he's trying to accomplish
and i think he's trying to find
something
away from the court and i wonder if they
will connect
you know so about
up until about 10 seconds ago i was
annoyed up until about 10 seconds ago i
was annoyed at the fact
that we didn't turn around inside
baseball that we didn't turn around
the kyrie irving sound from i don't know
how long ago it was
for the beginning of the show but
actually it's rather apropos it's
actually rather fitting
and the reason is rather fitting because
i honestly don't care what he said
and i honestly i honestly never cared
even coming into today i didn't care if
he didn't talk to us
so it's actually kind of representative
of my feelings on the matter that wasn't
scripted but the more i thought about it
was like who cares what kyrie irving
said
and who cares whether he talks to the
media or not i know fans don't care
whether he talks to the media or not i
can tell i think fans do care
no they don't because if they want to
hear from him they could log into his ig
live
or they could hold on gary they could
log into his ig live
or they could um you know follow him on
twitter or anything else
i mean i know that fans have never been
sympathetic toward us
as members of the music oh i get that so
people are not co-op right that's
basically what i'm getting at but
sometimes i'm on their side
sometimes i'm understand sometimes
but even but even whether kyrie irving
you know whether he looks at us as pawns
and by the way
i didn't take offense to it because
number one hit dogs holler i don't view
myself as a pawn
i don't consider myself a pawn but if
that's how he looks at the media in
general
all right i guess there's probably
something to be said for because we're
all part of a larger machine
you know what i mean a lot of us ain't
cashing our own checks for that matter
we're not writing the checks
and so it didn't offend me him referring
to the media as pawns no matter how much
try to take it back today
i i know that's what he meant but that's
okay to whom it made concern
if the shoe fits where or if you're at
the university of florida
throw it might get to that later on
we'll see anyway
um and i think a lot of it has to do
with uh the marshawn lynch
experienced them a couple of years ago
different people um
buddy-centric or eclectic if you prefer
what have you
interesting personalities different
rationale a friend of mine named david
shields
i highly recommend you watch this film
it's called uh lynch
history and it looks at um marshawn
lynch's media boycott a couple years ago
remember you know i'm just here so i
won't get fined
yeah it looks like that a couple of
years ago um
and it looks at it through the prism of
not only oakland's tradition
of protests and revolution but
the larger uh history of athlete
protests
um and i i looked at his boycott a
little a little more
uh deeply after watching david shields
film film i highly recommend it and i'm
not suggesting that this is kyrie irving
attempted to make some kind of political
statement i don't read it as that even
though he did quote malcolm x
uh i just i'm over i'm over
begging people to do something they
don't want to do because there's enough
people in the locker room there's enough
people around the league first of all
eight million stories and there's enough
people around the league
that are willing uh to tell their
stories are willing to try to control
and shape their own narratives
or willing to use the media media or
manipulate the media as the case may be
um there are enough guys who get it who
get their responsibility
and responsibility is not always
synonymous with burden but who get their
responsibility and their obligation to
help grow the game and promote the game
there's plenty of guys in that locker
room and around the league that are more
than willing
to talk to the media where i ain't got
to beg beg for him to do it
not to mention is kyrie irving going to
say something so profound
that i gotta hear it from him he might
he might
he might okay great this is why he's
great this is why i think
this is why i disagree with you this is
why i disagree with you and you say fans
don't necessarily want to hear him talk
because they want to hear him they can
go to instagram
no no no no no no excuse me no no they
don't want they don't care if he talks
to us or not that's the
because we're because remember we're the
enemy long before donald trump
we were the we've always been the enti
the enemy
the the fourth estate the entity that is
the media the mainstream media has
always been the enemy
so we get no sympathy from from no
questions you know that
and kyrie irving should know he's not
the first person to believe in uh
conspiracy theories and hate the media
okay he's not the first and we
and as you just pointed out uh there's a
great example uh
leaving our country right now but this
is where i disagree with you
after a game after a playoff game for
example they're going to be in the
playoffs it's going to be a really good
team
with kevin durant and kyrie irving
they're going to be a really good team
after a playoff game uh where he scores
40 points
they win by a point they lose by a point
he's
involved in a play of the game yeah you
do want to hear those
those situations the podium you want it
as a fan
now that's different than kyrie irving
telling you about what's important to
him away from basketball
uh talking about music or movies or
shoes or anything else or political uh
political endeavors that's that's for
instagram and twitter
away from the game but i do think fans
want to hear especially
in the moment i think you're too close
to it because it's not it's not as
though we are the only oh
i'm not i'm not close to it at all thank
god
thank god you say fans want to hear it
and i'm and i look at it from a fan
perspective
you like when kyrie irving was in boston
i wasn't covering the celtics
i didn't need him to talk to me i didn't
need him to do my job but i did enjoy
hearing from him i wanted to hear
his analysis of something that i just
watched but you're not you're not a fan
michael you
you might be a fan at heart but no i
mean
in the truest sense okay like you you
bit it
both of us and this isn't i'm not
pointing the finger at you both of us
been in this game too long
to consider ourselves fam we fans we
can't just look at things
through the the prism of an average fan
who follows him on instagram
or follows him on twitter or or or
follows whatever content that he puts
out
uh independent of the mainstream media
you're talking about and set aside you
know covet
and the zoom press conferences nowadays
you're talking about
back in the day when they be at the
podium and you got the media
you know gathering and somebody would
ask a crazy question and and
it'd be a viral moment or somebody might
ask a good question it leads to a good
answer
that process let's just call it that
process
of of working with the press is not
something that i think fans are
are clamoring for yeah it would be nice
and it often leads to some great sound
bites
but it's not it more often than not it
leads to scrutiny of the media
because more often than that you got
people saying why would that such a
sense that's that crazy question
or somebody getting up walking off you
know it's something it's one of those
moments
but really got something so insightful
that it can't be related to his fans or
his followers
without a a microphone with a flag from
a major network across and i think we'd
be remiss though i think we'd be remiss
if we just don't point out again
and i know a lot of people know this but
we got to point it out one more time you
talk about
hey you know he doesn't want to do it
and i don't need to hear from him i'll
tell you who disagrees with you
uh let's start with adam silver and and
everybody
in the uh nba apparatus because it's
part of the job
it's part of the job for players to
speak that's why it keeps getting fine i
have
uh something to say on that in a second
i get that i totally get so whether
whether we think if he doesn't do it it
falls on somebody else to do it
it's in the contract for a reason don't
get me wrong i understand that i
understand that perspective
i just come from it from a different
place i guess just at my this point in
my life in my career
i'm just not wanting to chase these
dudes like that you know maybe it's
because i don't have to do it anymore
but even when i had to do it it's cool
that's it i go i go
i go find somebody else well but but
i've done it though
but i have done it i know i know what i
mean i used to do right no but i'm
saying i used to do it
and michael even when i used to do it i
was never one
to get all hot and bothered about the
fact that somebody wasn't giving me
access
but so i'm speaking from a privileged
position i understand the people that
have to do it now
may feel differently and yes you're
right it's in the contract for a reason
adam silver you know mandates it the
league mandates it
it's tradition but here's the thing man
and this goes for kyrie irving
or anybody else this game this game will
be here
he's going to come and go they all come
and go the ones who want to talk to the
media don't talk to the media
they'll we'll be here longer than they
will now they'll have a whole lot more
money
and more people will know them but when
he's done playing
this machine is going to keep rolling
this you know and a lot of them that
don't want to talk to the media end up
wanting to be members of the media
kyrie irving probably maybe we'll or
become members you know media
or do or actually become members of that
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah but
but you know i i said i wanted to say
something about kyrie
and his statement when he wasn't talking
and as i said i understand
i i do understand at times there are
certain
reporters that you don't like
there's certain storylines that you
don't you don't want to deal with
and at some point you just take
responsibility
you take control of your story which is
uh what kyrie said he was doing taking
control of his own platform
and then making the decision hey i'm not
going to play your game all right i
understand that
this is one thing though and i'm going
to take him
at his word that he is more concerned
about the vulnerabilities right now that
are happening to certain communities
including in brooklyn
where the unemployment rate is 16 all
right 16
in brooklyn uh and it's higher in other
communities
i think the bronze bronze is like 30
it's unbelievable
so when i say if you going to take
control of your story
and you don't want to talk to the media
that's cool
but what you're doing is you're talking
about vulnerable communities
unemployment off the charts you want to
do something to help you are giving 25
dollars to the nba and allowing the nba
to do what it feels is responsible with
that money yeah it goes to nba charities
but it's not your charities
and it's not your voice it's not your
impact you control the dollars so what i
would say
if he wanted to keep it going all season
if he really wanted to do it
i'd say all right don't talk to the
media all year release your statements
every time you're going to get fined uh
uh
25 thousand dollars uh you direct where
the money is going to go
or you don't just give that money away
you say you use your media availability
to talk about what's important to you
that happened
right so i if he's going to do it that
way
i say just go all in go all in and do it
and help somebody because 25 like i know
you can afford it
but yeah he could donate to nba
charities and do whatever he wants with
the rest of his money mike
there are there are some people where 25
000 right now could change their lives
so uh there's a there's an anti-poverty
uh
organization uh here in boston uh doc
rivers does some work with it
um i i contributed something uh
a couple weeks ago and i was blown away
by one of the stats that
that the amount of people in boston who
are on the verge
of of foreclosing of being evicted
because because of covet so yeah
nationwide
that's that's not a boston story that's
not a boston story
that's not a that's not a story just in
the state of connecticut that is
all over that's all over the country
it's in every nba city
if you're going to be about it just just
i say take
more control but it's a little absolute
for me i don't mean
i'm not i don't think i misunderstand
what you're saying but okay he can still
give 25 000
to nba charity because at the time he
didn't want to talk to the media and
still give to
give investigations that he wants
because his pocket changes to him
because his pocket changes you know i
could change him
but what no exactly that's my pleasure
it's going to nba charity
see we can we're getting too far off the
deep end here is going no no
i'm not i'm not i'm just i'm i'm not i'm
not trying to i'm just going to say this
if if you are concerned if you're if
you're a mission if you're saying to the
media this is what he said to the media
stay focused enjoy the art we got
bigger things to worry about right now
especially now
in this time that's what he said that's
his message you go back to his
his statement that's it i think i just
summarized it
so if that's your message even though
you can afford to just throw away
25 000 or give it to the nba which is
not really crazy about the nba because
you don't like the nba policies
don't do that don't do that just come
out they're not mutually exclusive
they're not mutually exclusive he can
still they don't have to mutually
how do you know that he's not how do you
know that he's i didn't say he's not
talking
but that 25 grand is not going where he
wants it to go is my point that's all
it's not where he wants it to go because
he's not in control of that
so if you're gonna just give away money
give away money
in addition to the money that you're
already giving away i'm not saying he's
not
but in addition to the money that you've
already given away for good causes
take the extra 25 grand nba uh you're
not you're not gonna hold that for me
anymore
i'm gonna sit here i'll do what i need
to do media wise
but i'm not gonna just throw away 25
grand
when i know during this time
somebody somebody could use it and and
let nba charities come up with uh
fines from somebody else not for me for
just because i don't want to talk to the
media right now
okay um i didn't come into this show
planning to talk about this but he spoke
today
uh i actually did want to talk about his
art capital a
uh which we'll do after the break but
gary if you would be so kind
uh so as to make sure that we did not uh
misconstrue
kyrie irving's words uh we should
probably play
his song from today on the way out so
let's play the sound from today on the
way out
go to break and then we come back uh
with kyrie irving's art because i do
want to appreciate his art capital a i
like the capitalization thing michael
what you're talking about
the focus is on what's going on in the
task here
you know my job and i wanted to make
sure that that was clear
no distractions nothing about dispelling
anything
nothing about going back and forth
knowing about calling out one person or
another
not even refer to you guys as pawns you
know what i mean or media it's just
really how i felt about
the mistreatment of certain artists when
we get to a certain platform
of when we make decisions within our
lives to have full control and ownership
you know we we go through the rigorous
season
we do everything we're asked to do you
know and we want to perform
in a secure and protective space and if
i can't have my voice protected on this
platform where i
offer myself and my art just inviting
everyone to it because
this is what i've been blessed to do
i've been blessed to do it
you know i didn't i didn't make it from
the best circumstances i made it because
my family had a foundation and taught me
the right things
how the principal led life so having
that in basketball in my art
you know it's just finding a balance you
know and that's all so to answer your to
to answer your first question
um can you ask that to go on ask that
one again
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you